i
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález de acuerdo
con el informe anual de la revista
británica the economist la democracia
mundial ha sufrido un retroceso sin
precedentes por segundo año consecutivo
este reporte hizo foco en los sistemas
de gobierno de los países que ha
analizado y en las medidas aplicadas
para hacer frente a la pandemia de kobe
19 que en muchos casos resultaron muy
estrictas pero necesarias en muchos de
los casos para que de manera directa
pues terminarán ellas estas medidas
afectando los indicadores democráticos
de algunos de los países según el
reporte el índice en 2020 era de 5.37 y
cayó en solamente un año hasta 5.28 esto
representa la mayor caída desde el año
2010 cuando los indicadores cayeron se
vinieron al piso debido a la crisis
financiera a nivel mundial
el punto más débil a nivel mundial es
américa latina la democracia en nuestra
región va en caída libre en un descenso
rápido y sostenido en los últimos seis
años pero el 2021 es un año de cuidado
porque no solo ubica la región de
américa latina como la de mayor
deterioro democrático sino que también
nuestra región rompió el récord en el
descenso más contundente desde que the
economist comenzó la publicación de este
informe en el año 2006 cuáles son
entonces los aspectos que evalúa este
informe veamos son cinco indicadores en
total evalúa el proceso electoral y
pluralismo el funcionamiento del
gobierno y la participación política la
cultura política que tiene cada país y
también las libertades civiles esta
evaluación fue realizada en 165 estados
independientes y dos territorios
puntuales
de acuerdo con los resultados que
arrojan los estudios en cada uno de los
países
este estudio ubica a los estados en
cuatro categorías de acuerdo con la
salud que tengan sus democracias la
clasificación de acuerdo al tipo de
régimen es la siguiente según este
reporte democracia plena grupo al que
solamente pertenecen 21 países en todo
el mundo y es liderado por los países
nórdicos por noruega finlandia suecia
dinamarca e islandia y se une a ellos
también nueva zelanda en el pacífico sur
la segunda categoría es democracia y
perfecta le sigue régimen híbrido y
finalmente régimen régimen autoritario
grupo al que pertenecen cerca de 59
países alrededor del mundo
bueno entonces cómo le fue a los países
de américa ya los de la región de
américa latina' por supuesto nuestra
región ya lo decíamos no le fue muy bien
en el desempeño en este año veamos
primero el lado positivo de este listado
según el informe el top 5 de los países
más democráticos de américa lo vendría a
liderar canadá pero dentro de la región
de américa latina según este informe el
top 5 lo lidera uruguay que es
considerado como una democracia plena y
está ubicado en el puesto 13 a nivel
mundial le sigue costa rica también en
la misma categoría de democracia plena
ubicada en el puesto número 20 son los
únicos países ubicados en ese selecto
grupo que les decía de 21 países
considerados democracia plena en tercera
posición y cayendo está chile
considerado como una democracia
imperfecta en el puesto número 25 a
nivel mundial el cuarto lugar nos lleva
hasta a trinidad y tobago puesto número
41 a nivel mundial y lo cierra jamaica
con el puesto 42 a nivel mundial cierra
entonces este top 5 de democracias
digamos más saludables en américa
chile es un caso llamativo porque cayó
de categoría de democracia plena e
imperfecta ya vamos a ver cuáles fueron
los motivos en nuestro análisis más
adelante pasemos ahora entonces a los
países que están en el fondo del listado
en nuestro continente los cinco últimos
del ranking comenzamos con guatemala que
está en una línea muy muy delgada entre
ser considerado como un país con un
régimen autoritario o una democracia
híbrida digámoslo así un régimen híbrido
está en el puesto 99 a nivel mundial le
sigue haití en el puesto 119 a nivel
mundial nicaragua en el 140 cv base
ubica en el 142 a nivel mundial mientras
que venezuela es el último del
continente y se ubica en la posición
151 todos como les decía son
considerados países con un régimen
autoritario
cuál es entonces las causas para esta
caída general de nuestra región que
tanto ha afectado la situación de la
emergencia que trajo la pandemia del
joven 19 a la salud de nuestras
democracias qué tipo de gobiernos
estamos construyendo en américa latina
en donde también reina un descontento
ciudadano y la desconfianza en las
instituciones está presente la
democracia en américa latina sigue en
declive ese es nuestro tema de debate
hoy en france 24 y para analizarlo hemos
invitado a irene mía ella es líder del
programa de investigación sobre
seguridad gobernanza y geoeconomía del
instituto internacional para estudios
estratégicos ella se encuentra en la
ciudad de londres en el reino unido
también es en esta conversación desde la
ciudad de washington la capital de
estados unidos se conecta a michael
schifter el ex presidente de de
inter-american dialogue y ustedes
nuestros televidentes también pueden
participar en este debate dejando
comentarios y preguntas las pueden hacer
a través de nuestras redes sociales no
se encuentran en facebook en instagram
en twitter ustedes ya las conocen
france24 guión viajo
sant y luego que es mi cuenta personal
le recuerdo la etiqueta numeral el
debate 24 dejen todos sus comentarios y
sus preguntas sobre este tema que nos
concierne a todos en la región de
américa latina comienza entonces con
irene en la ciudad de londres
preguntándole en la sensación que deja
este informe es que américa latina está
comenzando a llegar digamos a un abismo
en donde después de seis años de
continuo descenso la región
se acerca a una zona peligrosa en cuanto
a la salud de su democracia qué
sensación le dejó a usted este informe
gracias por la pregunta y muy buenas
tardes o noches como estoy en londres es
decir yo creo que ese índice claro como
lo comentó usted tiene muchos
componentes no entonces es solamente
mira mira mira diferentes aspectos de
que tengo que latino clase entonces
también la presentación electoral la
cultura democrática
la funcionamiento del gobierno que aquí
yo creo que es el problema realmente en
esa insatisfacción con la con la
democracia yo creo que
no es tan una
insatisfacción con la democracia y creo
que es más la frustración con el modelo
económico socioeconómico y de desarrollo
que se ha seguido en las últimas de las
últimas décadas en la región y con eso
en el aspecto que comentaba de la
calidad de la gobernanza pública y del
funcionamiento del gobierno y eso es
porque es lo que vimos mucho con mucho
con mucha calidad en la pandemia y es
algo que era meter índice registra y eso
es la insatisfacción ponerla con el
nivel
con el cual el gobierno realmente
enfrentado
y eso es algo que ya se veía en los
últimos desde 2000
hemos visto que eso de una forma es la
opinión de idn mía en la ciudad de
londres yo les compartía que la
sensación que me deja es que como que
américa latina está empezando a caminar
por un borde de un abismo
riesgoso digámoslo así pero que estamos
en la coyuntura del cobi 19 quiero
conocer la opinión de michael schifter
en la ciudad de washington para conocer
su opinión y la sensación que le deja
usted este informe michael
bueno muchas gracias
bueno este este informe más o menos
coincide con muchos estudios y encuestas
que se ha hecho últimamente
de la tendencia de deterioro en la
compromiso o satisfacción con la
democracia por los ciudadanos en américa
latina
y yo creo que hay que reconocer que
desde el año 2013
la economía
micheletti nació más o menos estancada
que los niveles de pobreza y desigualdad
que había bajado antes en la primera
parte de este siglo se ha vuelto a subir
y que la capacidad de gobiernos para
atender las necesidades de su gente
ha bajado mucho y esto es una fórmula
para muchos descontento social y muchos
movimientos en
movilización en las calles que fue
clarísimo al finales de 2019 antes de la
pandemia y con también ha grabado mucho
sabemos que américa latina fue la región
en el mundo más golpeado de todas las
regiones ha tenido retrocesos económicos
más fuertes y esto creo que
ha sido muy difícil para tener
gobiernos nacionales que son capaces de
realmente funcionar bien y yo creo que
la exploración principal por el declive
que estamos viendo a ver quiero que
hagamos análisis de diferentes temas que
hay sobre la mesa con este informe
michael lo mencionaba el tema de la
pandemia afectó mucho a la región de
américa latina hubo un difícil acceso a
las vacunas ahí quedó evidente más
desigualdad en cuanto a los países y al
interior de los mismos países el acceso
a internet para garantizar el
teletrabajo y la educación remota entre
otros temas pero el tema de la pandemia
es uno de los focos que tiene este
informe como uno de los agravantes de
este declive como entiende uno cómo
explicar irene que las medidas que
tuvieron que tomar los gobiernos para
poder hacer frente a esta emergencia
sanitaria jugaron en contra de la salud
democrática de los países y eran unas
medidas necesarias para poder garantizar
la salud la buena salud de los
habitantes
e
es decir yo creo que no fue tan eso no
son tantos los medios es bueno eso es
algo que tuvimos en todo en todo el
mundo un poco ese ese contraste gente
que decía bueno es algo antidemocrático
y aquí hay eso es un tema general yo
creo que en el caso de américa latina la
pandemia realmente lo que agravó fue lo
que realmente hizo muy claros fueron
estas desigualdades que en qué marco
también destaca
una región donde hay un mercado informa
de nuevo méxico hay acceso igualitario a
los sistemas de salud todos las cosas se
agravaron mucho con la pandemia de la
pandemia hizo que todo el mundo lo viera
verdad entonces lo que hemos visto
también nosotros por ejemplo en nuestro
informe nosotros hacemos en forma cada
uno sobre los conflictos armados
señalamos también a la altura todo el
tema de la gobernancia en américa latina
lo que hemos visto que todo el mundo el
doctor mundo ha visto ese por ejemplo el
hecho de que los cárteles la salud de
los grupos criminales solamente
como casi casi han comenzado a tener una
función de becas en español generalmente
ayudando
tardando con la comida los servicios
básicos y está claro es algo que no hay
una gobernanza y la confianza en los
gobiernos
michael lo mencionamos estas medidas
fueron impuestas para hacer frente a
esta emergencia pero poco a poco se está
recuperando la normalidad los estados
vuelven a sus formas de gobernanza
normales y los habitantes vuelven a sus
rutinas poco a poco también la economía
poco a poco se está estabilizando o está
volviendo a despegar en algunos de los
países esto quiere decir que entonces
estamos
ante un
ante la posibilidad de reversar ese
declive democrático en los próximos
meses una vez regrese a la normalidad y
la pandemia pase o por lo menos se
tranquilice un poco
bueno hay aquí el país el país no es
cierto es cierto lo que usted dice que
algunas señales más alentadores pero la
región va a crecer como en total a pérez
2% está en el 2022 el país grande como
brasil está más o menos no va a crecer
tiene problemas económicos muy muy duros
y en otros países también claro hay
algunos que están despegando como
colombia y en alguna forma de perú pero
la situación económica sigue siendo
compleja en el gran parte de
la región y otro tema del liderazgo
político que ha faltado liderazgo
político fue por el fue puesto a prueba
con la pandemia no hubo una una
respuesta muy alentadora de los líderes
de muchos países fueron irresponsables
negaron que hubo una pandemia y no
tomaban las medidas necesarios
incluye eeuu en todo esto dicho sea de
paso y yo creo que yo creo que tenemos
en la región díaz estructuras políticas
muy muy
fragmentadas y un nivel de publicación
muy alto en muchos países entonces yo
creo que tomará tiempo para recomponer
la situación política en los países
porque los partidos los partidos
políticos tradicionales no están
funcionando bien y tenemos casos como
chile cuando tiene una lección con los
primeros cuatro candidatos la primera
vuelta son outsiders totales pero algún
outsider viene elecciones de colombia oa
qué cosa puede pasar
imbécil también o sea hay un gran nivel
de incertidumbre que genera no solamente
la situación económica y social pero un
poco la falta el liderazgo político y
también partidos políticos eficaces y
creíbles maikel continuó con usted para
hacer la ronda a la inversa ya le doy la
palabra irene y sigo por la línea de lo
que usted está comentando hay una falta
de liderazgo hemos visto casos muy
puntuales el presidente castillo de perú
él mismo ha dicho que es una persona que
no está capacitada para gobernar que no
sabía cómo que no sabe cómo gobernar y
vemos los problemas que está enfrentando
perú el presidente de colombia en su
momento también enfrentó las mismas
críticas por falta de liderazgo y de
experiencia a la hora de gobernar como
darle entonces tranquilidad a la
población cuando hay falta de liderazgo
cuando no hay personajes políticos de
peso a quienes se les pueda elegir
democráticamente para que tomen las
riendas del país no hay partidos
institucionalizados de manera fuerte en
las elecciones que hemos presenciado en
los últimos meses y fuera de eso la
democracia
andando pues por por unas rutas muy
complicadas como lo estamos analizando
cómo darle a la gente entonces
tranquilidad confiar en el sistema en el
gobierno de las instituciones que esa es
una gran queja creería yo a nivel
continental
bueno exactamente usted lo ha señalado
el problema lo que estaríamos estamos
viendo son respuestas más populistas en
el caso de salvador bucal y es muy
popular pero hay un rechazo de todos los
partidos de presión de partidos
políticos tradicionales todas las
instituciones democráticas y esto esto
ya ya conocemos este tipo de fenómeno de
líderes populistas no generan resultados
sostenibles no satisfacen las
necesidades de la gente ahora ahí vamos
a ver lo que pase en el sil y los nuevos
gobiernos siempre habrán posibilidades
hay una situación interesante y también
el posible parece que lo marcó ver el
escenario en brasil es el regreso de
lula da silva que es un líder obviamente
muy experimentado con mucha habilidad
que juega no solamente a nivel nacional
pero a nivel regional y global y esto
podría esto podría empezar a cambiar un
poco la dinámica y la clima política en
el perú
en el américa latina pero es muy
importante que hay otros liderazgos que
surgen que pueden cumplir ese papel
irene liderazgos y populismo también son
mencionados en este reporte
citan casos muy puntuales en la región
de américa latina que ya ha comenzado a
mencionar los michael habla de jair
bolsonaro en brasil andrés manuel lópez
obrador en mexico en allí bukle en el
salvador que son gobiernos a los que se
les critica por acoso a periodistas
captación del poder judicial ataques a
las instituciones democráticas se me
viene a la mente en este momento como
ejemplo los ataques que hacía el
presidente bolsonaro a la autoridad
electoral de su país que fue
precisamente la misma autoridad que
avaló su elección popular por votos de
los brasileños fue la misma autoridad
que lo que lo eligió avaló su elección y
el mismo sale a criticar que el sistema
no funciona que es corrupto y que no
puede garantizar elecciones libres en
las próximas en los próximos comicios el
populismo cada vez está tomando fuerza
en américa latina' esto claramente va en
detrimento de la gracias pero se está
volviendo tal vez para los ciudadanos
una forma una elección viable buscando
respuestas a estos problemas
estructurales que venimos arrastrando
si la verdad es que algo que es una
tendencia que estamos viendo en la
región no solamente en la región en
otros en otras partes del mundo creo que
eso es algo como decía relacionado con
la insatisfacción con el sistema como
está ahora no solo democracia como ha
funcionado hasta ahora y esa tentación
de ir para elegir a alguien vista
diferente con toda la bailes
el himno de que se vayan todos no en
américa latina entonces es esa idea de a
lo mejor no es tan importante que
realmente los derechos democráticos sean
espectador pero sí es importante que se
hará algo entonces yo creo que lo que
decía grecia maicon en su verdad hay que
ver cómo esos populistas van a
asegurar las zonas las demandas de la
revolución yo creo que lo que hay que
hay que destacar dispositivo es que es
verdad que la participación democrática
es algo que ya es muy fuerte
que tiene una
[Música]
a un lado un poco un poco más
problemático en punto lo que tuve que
vimos en términos de protestas también
quiere decir que la población sabe sus
derechos lo que quiere y realmente
quiere un modelo distinto quiere hacer
solo servicios básicos quiere menos
desigualdad en el sistema yo creo que el
problema va a ser para los populistas y
los gobiernos no populistas el programa
ser que como decía michael hay muchos
elementos de inestabilidad en la región
hay restricción económica claro de
recuperación pero también hay muchas
incertidumbres en términos de vacunas
gravosa con la pandemia
y hay mucho algún vídeo creo que el
problema fundamental es que hay muchas
expectativas en la población y que los
gobiernos van a estar muy limitado en su
capacidad de atender a esas esas
prioridades de sus demandas porque
realmente después de la pandemia su
margen de maniobra fiscal
es muy
entonces creo que este es el problema y
es que hay por ejemplo de la el consejo
constitucional de la gran estudiante en
chiles algo muy interesante porque la
verdad es democracia en acción nueva
pero la verdad es cómo se va a
implementar las recomendaciones yo creo
que esos son los problemas cómo van a
ser los populismos y los gobiernos
democráticos para poder atender a las
demandas de aplicación que sigan ahí
siguen sin gran alarma desde 2019 y
antes claro también hay que decir que
muchos países de américa latina son
democracias muy jóvenes son países que
hace no menos de 40 años estaban
terminando gobiernos dictatoriales
reconstruyendo sus formas de gobierno su
confianza en las instituciones y en los
gobernantes y bueno esto es un proceso
que toma tiempo también lo vemos en
algunos países de europa del este que
tal vez lo han hecho un poco más rápido
que américa latina en ese paso de unas
dictaduras a gobiernos democráticos eso
en cuanto a las líneas generales que
quería analizar el informe quiero pasar
a casos puntuales y quiero comenzar por
los países que están en el fondo de la
lista considerados como regímenes
autoritarios está hablando puntualmente
de nicaragua de cuba y de venezuela son
países que desde hace varios años los
vemos allí en el fondo de la tabla
qué hacer con estos países allí
definitivamente el aparato del estado se
encarga de hostigar a los opositores
generar controversias con represión con
problemas económicos y sociales
que análisis se puede hacer de esos tres
casos maicon
bueno yo creo que él tal vez donde hemos
visto el retroceso más dramático y más
grave y preocupante hacia una casa en
nicaragua sekouba ha sido un régimen
autoritario por por desde la versión
cubana por 60 años y no ha cambiado
mucho lamentablemente permitará agua y
yo creo que
lo que estamos viendo en términos de la
represión sistemática
de todo todos los que están en la
oposición los candidatos para la
presidencia en noviembre estar
encarcelados tienen estos juicios que
son una broma que no respeta ningún
ningún proceso jurídico yo creo que es
muy dramático lo que está pasando ahí
hay medidas de denuncia a nivel
internacional hay acciones individuales
pero hasta ahora ortega
y su vicepresidente su esposa rosario
murillo no han no han
estado dispuesto a negociar y hablar
entonces eso es gravísimo y en venezuela
por lo menos hay un proceso de
negociaciones que ha empezado en méxico
que está suspendido por momento pero se
espera que eso se puede reactivar ese
proceso para ver si se puede ver una una
negociación política para preparar el
terreno para una rendición democrática
que no va a ser fácil pues por cierto
pero yo creo que es posible y hay que
por lo menos
explorar esa opción claro el caso de
venezuela llama mucho la atención de la
comunidad internacional sobre todo por
eso 5,9 millones de venezolanos que han
huido de la emergencia humanitaria ese
éxodo venezolano y el caso nicaragüense
lo explicaba michael por el tema de las
recientes elecciones donde prácticamente
no hubo oposición y hubo una persecución
abierta a muchos de los candidatos que
todavía están presos sin un proceso
judicial
como lo marca la constitución
nicaragüense
irene y presiones de estos tres casos
antes de pasar la página y pasar a los
casos positivos con los que podemos
sacar pecho en laja en la región de
américa latina' aire en sus impresiones
de cuba nicaragua y venezuela
sí es decir tengo una visión muy
parecida a la de michael y creo que la
verdad que venezuela a lo mejor es para
mí los más preocupantes por sus impactos
geopolíticos en la región
los 33 son casos muy difíciles yo creo
que también hay que mencionar que este
año bajo de que tengo y otra vez es esta
hora en las teorías de
[Música]
y eso yo creo que es algo bastante va a
ser bastante dramático es bastante
interesante porque realmente es un país
donde después de la
trujillo de la de presidente es un país
que realmente
ya casi no tiene
gobernancia ella no solamente escribirá
son las bandas armadas que están
haciendo que están realmente asegurando
la gobernanza en el país entonces yo
creo que eso es algo que es un caso
extremo pero es un caso que estamos
viendo en muchas partes de la región
después de una pandemia
ese es a
esos dos regímenes paralelos de una
parte la la gobernancia oficial del
gobierno y de la otra la versión sea
criminal yo creo que es algo que vamos a
ver mucho más a menudo porque las bandas
con las bandas criminales van a volverse
cada vez más un actor político entonces
yo creo que es algo que vamos a ver
también en países más estables y es suma
es solamente suma tendencia muy
preocupante como si de hecho el informe
cita el narcotráfico y los diferentes
carteles como un punto importante
también a analizar sobre todo por la
expansión que ha habido en suramérica
han llegado ya ramificaciones de
carteles mexicanos y colombianos a chile
a ecuador en donde se ha visto un
incremento de violencia en ciertas
regiones en ciertos puntos quiero pasar
la página y hablar de los
países destacados uruguay y costa rica
están en ese selecto grupo de 21 países
que tienen la categoría de democracia
plena que ha funcionado en estos países
michaels que ha dado buenos resultados
tendrán sus problemas a mejorar en los
gobiernos están haciendo frente por
supuesto pero institucionalmente son
fuertes los gobiernos cumplen funcionan
y la gente
se siente en una democracia plena donde
es tomada en cuenta siendo una minoría o
siendo parte de los diferentes
escalafones de la sociedad sobre todo
llama la atención el caso uruguay porque
como lo decía hace 40 años uruguay
estaba en una dictadura entonces su
construcción democrática ha sido
bastante rápida
bueno pero antes de la dictadura
uruguay tenía una actualización
democrática de chile y también los
dictadores fueron una excepción entonces
recuperaron la democracia lucharon mucho
mucho costo muy alto pero lograron
recuperar la democracia tanto en chile
como en uruguay y creo que andy tiene
una tradición muy
constitucionalista muy se ve lista
y creo que hay normas democráticas y
conocimiento de instituciones como
congreso como poder judicial que
funciona bastante bien y hay libertades
políticos que están protegidos entonces
yo creo que hay una cultura política
bastante fuerte en el caso uruguay
también costa rica yo creo que en chile
también tener chile es un call uno los
tres casos que ha bajado un poco dado un
poco la crisis en el país y alto nivel
de publicación y otros y otros procesos
sensibles
pero a los tres países siempre están muy
altos
en la lista estuario la mente entonces
no es extraño ver que están destacados
en este en esta encuesta también si
chile este año pasó de ser una
democracia plena a una democracia
imperfecta de acuerdo a este índice es
uno de los casos destacados para estudio
este año con este informe junto con
españa que también sale del grupo de los
20 países de democracia plena y pasa a
ser un país de democracia imperfecta
impresiones sobre costa rica y el caso
uruguay y bueno también el caso de chile
que como lo decimos es interesante ver
cómo baja debido a ese estallido social
que presenció hace algunos meses atrás
irene
sí es decir creo que lo que lo que
nuestro dijo es verdad yo creo que son
dos países que donde hay mucha confianza
sesiones porque las instituciones por lo
normal funcionan bien los niveles de
corrupción son muy bajos para
comparar estándares de la región y son
países son también son países pequeños
siempre es más fácil también
implementar organizar y
gestionado el caso de chile es
interesante yo creo que bajó mirando los
indicadores es algo que tiene que ver
con
emergencia de
la zona
y también si también la parte de la
polarización en las elecciones yo creo
que
y de hecho me parece que está que
también el informe es un retroceso pero
en realidad hay también muchos elementos
positivos y ese es el proceso
constitucional de la de la senda
constituyentes es algo positivo porque
realmente fue una manera para de una
forma que analizar
la insatisfacción en un proceso
constitucional entonces yo creo que
también es un reflejo de la de las
instituciones fuertes que el país tiene
para el cierre del programa quiero que
analicemos el caso de china que es el
país que da el título a este informe que
se llama el desafío de china
justamente hace un análisis del temor
que hay en occidente y sobre todo en
eeuu que este régimen autoritario que
gobierna en china este gobierno
comunista con ese éxito que ha tenido a
nivel económico y esa reducción de la
pobreza y modernización del país allá
y tratado de establecer unas bases que
sean atractivas para otros gobiernos que
quieran seguir de pronto este tipo de
camino y que resulte como en una especie
de desafío para la democracia tal y como
la conocemos en occidente irene sus
impresiones de el caso chino de esta
lectura que hacen que puede ser un
desafío para el tipo democracias que
conocemos
y yo diría que en el caso de américa
latina el desafío es muy presente porque
claro
si miramos a las incursiones que china
ha hecho en la región en los últimos
diez o quince años son enormes no las
chinas ya es el primer socio comercial
si uno considera méxico y no solamente
la parte comercial yo creo que es muy
importante la parte de la infiltración
la de la infiltración en la cena la
estructura de
internas temáticas
y
desarrollo tecnológico y eso creo que es
interesante porque realmente no
simplemente creo que la película
solamente la
el atractivo del modelo de china sino
también esta posibilidad de china de
poder realmente influenciar lo que está
pasando en la región y la verdad es que
como hay muchas adicciones hubo muchas
elecciones han pasado a elecciones
importante ahora en arena en colombia y
en brasil nada queda en mi mini
preocupación sería más bien como él como
china puede realmente influenza
interesante el debate político y
polarizar
y me quedan un poco más de 30 segundos o
michael sus impresiones para el cierre
del programa sobre el caso chino bueno
bueno yo creo que el caso chino
obviamente tiene mucha influencia y
mucha presencia que va a crecer en la
región el gran tema es la ausencia de
eeuu es un vacío y antes por mucho
tiempo eeuu fue como un modelo o tenía
como un mundial o pero un poco una
minería de clase gates e interesante
democrática y ya no es por lo que ha
pasado aquí ese es el gran
que hay que tener en cuenta pues en ella
michael les agradezco por haber estado
con nosotros para analizar este tema
aquí en el debate de france 24 ustedes
pueden seguir dejando sus comentarios y
sus preguntas y sigan en sintonía de
france 24
[Música]